[Music]
not only do you enjoy the camaraderie of
it but you make long-time friendships we
know the family we know the friend we
know what they do and how they travel in
life when people say we go by and check
on it when people go to jail we checked
on no other places this place is
absolutely necessary for our live
situation and carry on the traditions
that brought us through the rough back
[Music]
I'm tell Roberts and I came to DC in
1953 I've been playing checkers all of
my life at eight or nine years old I
hated everything in life I hated school
I hated everybody I couldn't read I
couldn't write but when I got on the
checkerboard I could see that if I moved
in moved yeah I'd get an advantage on it
and when I learned how to play checkers
I learned how to communicate so I went
from a dunce to a halfway decent person
and so check has changed my life anybody
playing this game it will change your
life also and checkers brings about a
camaraderie that you will never find
anywhere in life again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is Kurdish brothers who call me
hard rock where summer holidays Chuck a
player that you can Ella me I'm Robert
Mac now I'm the z-man you coach the
coach they know the pain he means what
they call mr. Mackey's name Donald
Cunningham better known as a pressure
man I do not have a nickname yet I like
to think that I'm waiting until I get
good enough that way it's a actually a
good nickname it doesn't become just an
insult something like that
he's a friend of man but on the boys he
wants to be me there and of course he
gets lucky every now and then we got
some free good checker players here then
we got some hands I lost one game today
and the honor is not lost because I fell
sorrowful I could I could have just been
undefeated and hands won't see they good
but ham is just ham
you know sometimes and had to call 9-1-1
cuz that's up thanke he's nothing man
you know you know you could get you eat
it and let it go and that's choice
that's the old show yeah
here like themselves I think I joined
this club a bit about about maybe 15 15
years ago I've been in the checker Club
for I don't know 20 years you know I've
definitely learned a lot over the last
year when I first came in there was no
way I was gonna win a game and now if
it's a good day then yeah I can win
sometimes and if it's a bad day you know
I'll get laughed out of here but I'd
never found a community like this around
a specific game and so I've really
enjoyed not just the game but the people
who come together to play it it's also a
community that I think should be
prioritised that we keep these
institutions alive and in DC in a city
that's rapidly kind of gentrifying and
becoming much richer that we don't lose
out on all the kind of historical and
cultural heritage that we've built not
only gentrification is coming in but
modernization is coming in and unless
there's a dramatic change at some point
in time there will not be a checkers
Club in Washington DC so it is
ultimately it is primarily important
that we keep this game going and we keep
our place right here in the nation's
capital
such that we can carry on the tradition
that has taken us throughout the life
well listen this song is a a spirited
moment thing now the one song that comes
into my mind is the is the Oh Smokey Joe
smokey on top of old smokey all covered
with snow I left my heart into a dough
hook nobody wants to hear that song so
[Music]
yeah I sing it at I ring the bell or you
see that bill over here that's it just a
bill that we we ring ring - bill are you
checking with manual dexterity like a
surgeon uses his scalpel
I do magical thing of checkup or hey I
got a nickname my nickname is the razor
[Music]